what does it mean to you to be a writer
writing is putting
down in a physical space
what only I can see in here
so writing is the act of basically
transmuting my inner world into the
outer world
so that you can see what's going on
inside me
in a way that is different from when we
have a conversation
because writing
has a really different voice from when
we speak I don't know some people write
exactly the way they speak and I'm like
yep I know especially over text like I
know over text I text the way that I
talk right
but that's very different from how I
approach creative writing my my voice as
a creative writer is different from how
I speak I think so it's it's just a it's
showing your inner world to the rest of
the world
what compels you to write
knowing that I have a story that only I
can tell
and knowing what it could do for people
you know being like
either it's a story that I'm really
excited about you know it's not it's not
as on the nose my feature script is is
just literally an excerpt from my life
that I think people should know about
um
but in terms of you know whether it's
it's something that's a little bit more
lighthearted and fun
um or not
it's just knowing that no one else is
going to tell it
and I have to be the one to do it so
it's like all right you know make time
schedule in your riding time as often as
you can
so that it gets tall it gets told it
gets done you know
you've created the thing and then you
can go into the rewrite process and keep
playing and exploring and growing and
go from there
can you walk us through your writing
process
interesting you say that you know we
were talking about
the difference between student and
artist I'm very much still a student of
creative writing you know I'm I'm still
developing my process is what I should
say I'm working with a mentor right now
who specifically Works to help female
writers find an organic process that
works for them so it's not about like by
the end of this course you'll have a
feature film ready to go it's very much
a like how do you not hate this
that's how I would bring into her course
um so I'm I'm still discovering I'm
still discovering every day and it's
it's fun to be in a I really like being
in a discovery process it's it's the
best part of it in my opinion because
there's no pressure there's no like oh I
have a deliverable that's due in eight
weeks it's like
cool let's try this do I like it do I
hate it I don't know let's try this how
do I feel about prompts how do I feel
about
um what do I do when I'm in a writer's
block you know and I'm like wow I don't
want to ever look at that script again I
don't want to write it you're going to
today
um if anything I I really sincerely wish
I made more time for it I think lately
producing and acting has been so like
busy in my life that it's like I almost
have sidelined it a bit and I definitely
have a goal of during the holiday season
making it a daily practice again and I'm
excited about that because I think
I think there's a longevity and a
freedom to finding a way to create your
own stuff completely independently in
this business
as much as you know why Art Is Beautiful
is because of collaboration right as
much as I fundamentally believe that
it is also just like it feels like a
vacation to be like I'm gonna tell a
story
doesn't matter if anyone ever sees it
only I am telling the story The End
um that is it's a great way to flex that
creative autonomous muscle as it were
right being like how would I tell the
story again it goes back into that sort
of just overall artistic sensibility and
process
um yeah I mean I I think so much of it
is about carving out time one thing I
learned from her is to set like a little
timer and be like here's a prompt and
you get 90 seconds and even if you have
more to say you get to say it so all of
a sudden every time you do a prompt
you're like you know like get as much as
you can and it really like it stops any
BS from from interrupting your flow
you're just like okay I'm in the flow
and sure enough after a couple of
prompts you're you just you're like I
hate that rule I'm just gonna keep
writing and all of a sudden you're
writing it's a great way to kind of like
bust through all of the excuses that we
come up with for not writing because
she's like that's writing for 90 seconds
a day I think you can make 90 seconds
and she's right and it always turns into
more which is great
so you have this writing coach but you
also have this High School teacher that
it sounds like was very influential yeah
do you still hear her I do I do and also
there is like um I've just read a
gazillion descripts from being a working
actor for 10 years right like I my God
it's almost been 10 years now huh
um I've I've read so many scripts that I
know what is effective and what isn't to
a degree of like cool I wrote a scene
and I can objectively be like this scene
is trash that didn't work let's try
something else as opposed to
God I feel like when you really get into
the flow with a character that character
writes for you it's like this really
trippy thing that I I wish everybody
could experience once in their life
because you're like am I possessed right
now but once you get like a really clear
sense of who your character is like
their backstory what influences them all
the same questions that you ask yourself
right of like who am I what are my
values what are my beliefs doing that
for each character they actually tell
you what they want to do and say like
you'll be like this is the scene where
this happens and like as I'm writing
I'll be like no
like Roseanne I'm making up a name
Roseanne doesn't want to do that
the scene's going this way and I'm like
whoa what did that just do to my story
so I think like there has to be that
Discovery process I think
all too often I see this very
clinical approach to writing in the
industry of like I'm gonna do five pages
a day
which is like
yeah are you I don't know is that really
when you're comparing like a random
script to like George R.R Martin and his
world right George and like I love the
guy and one day we'll get the Winds of
Winter
um
but he really takes his time because
he's building a world right and he gets
very clear and specific about how that
world Works to a level of detail that
I'm like that's your gift it's not my
gift and I'm very happy for you
um that's your unique genius ability but
I think you have to make it a
three-dimensional world you know you
have to really get to know your
characters almost like take your
characters out on proverbial little
dates to get to know them
um think about all the different
situations I mean some people say that
writing is like the greatest form of
being a sociopath because you like make
these beautiful people and get to know
them and love them and then you put them
in terrible situations and that is
writing
um and indeed that is like conflict in a
script but
um
irie I think you can tell when someone
has taken the time to build a world and
when someone is like here's my concept
and there's no depth to the writing you
can always tell
you can always tell
you said earlier that there's going to
be sometimes when that script's in the
drawer and you don't want to look at it
why would that be something that you
created that you were once excited about
what would
put a damper on that
a lot of reasons for the feature I'm
working on for me it's like it's almost
too close to home like it's too
vulnerable and I need to do a lot to
like make my space feel safe to be able
to explore that
um but other times it'll be good you
know if if you're painting the same
Sparrow over and over again at some
point you're going to be like if I paint
another Sparrow I'm gonna burn it right
like I don't you dare make me paint
another Sparrow
um and you just need to do something
else I think so much of being an artist
is like where do you find your your font
of inspiration and I feel like it's this
nebulous thing that we're all chasing
right I mean you know it it's like
sometimes you get inspired from the most
random thing like I'll get inspired from
like a dish of food and I'll be like oh
wow that opened up this whole thing and
it may or may not be related to what I'm
working on it might be like wow here's
this like totally weird new idea that I
have and I think it's important to go
chase that because there's something
even if that idea doesn't turn into like
a fully fleshed out thing you're gonna
learn something from that that's going
to make the screw up tidying in your
desk drawer feel fun again
have you ever thought about not writing
something so personal because yes okay
because I'm working on that oh you are
okay yes because then it wouldn't be
where there might be other issues but it
wouldn't be that oh this is revealing
too much I don't know if I want to go
there or whatever oh yeah no I'm I'm
working on one that couldn't be further
from me and that one's really fun it's
it's a lot of a lot of a lot of fun
because it's there's research then
involved you know and I I should say
with the caveat not like me trying to
write the story of a people that I am
not a part of you know because I think
when people are like I'm gonna write
about this this group of people and I am
not of that race or uh gender or you
know whatever have you
um I think that sometimes you it's not
great results but
for me it's like I'm I'm writing a
script of like an era that is completely
foreign to me and so it's really fun to
do the research and it's fun to be like
oh let's go in fact that's that's like
my candy script like it's like here's my
treat
because you did the script that's
medicine you know
and why do the script that's medicine is
it really necessary to get something so
personal out it is for the world it is
for me
um
it kind of crystallized for me when I
was giving a talk
um and I'm happy to talk about it but I
was actually institutionalized for my
mental health I was involuntarily
committed in 2019 and it was a terrible
terrible time
um you know there were human feces on
the ground they didn't feed us there
were bars on the Windows if you wanted
to go outside you could sit in a cage it
was a horrific dehumanizing process and
I I honestly
um had a good experience with the other
people in the center
but it was like a it was almost like an
Alice in Wonderland story in a way of
like oh my God where am I this is like a
totally new paradigm
um and for me it was like I want people
to know that we have so thoroughly
defunded that system
that when you need it not if but when
you need it
you're not going to a happy place
you're going to a very scary
traumatizing place
um so yeah I do really feel like it's an
important story to be told I don't think
most people know what those places are
like and it's something that I know only
I can tell
because it's my lived experience
so something like a Prozac Nation or a
Girl Interrupted is that yeah or like on
Short Term 12 like something like that
you know of like what's it like to be in
a facility what happens to you and not
in a way like I think there's a lot of
movies about the mental health hospital
system that like starts to get corny
where you like see people you know who
have something like schizophrenia who
are doing things and all of a sudden
it's like smackding on camera and you're
like what what message are we saying no
I just want to talk about what it was
like until like not in a documentary
perspective but like really not try to
get into other people's stories like
obviously there are supporting
characters it's a huge ensemble cast
film
um but
really try to steer away from any kind
of representation that's going to invoke
two-dimensional judgments from the
audience and instead be like here are
people who needed care who didn't get it
and also here are the people trying to
give care who don't have the resources
to give it and all of a sudden they're
pitted against each other in this Barren
violent space
um and everyone's just trying to survive
you know
have you had second thoughts ever about
getting it out there or it's something
that you know you need to do
yeah I know I know I need to do it I'm
not in a rush right like it's like I
know when there are times to work on it
it's gonna be the right time to not a
very eloquent way to say that but um I
I'm not rushed about it I'm not hurried
I'm not like I have to tell your script
or else in my life won't have meaning or
I'm not like
95 trying to like churn out my last
screenplay it's
um
I'm really
being gentle with myself in that process
and also I have this fun candy script
that I'm really excited about I'm a big
horror junkie and it's like a nude spin
on horror that I'm experimenting with so
it's fun to just like dive in and
tell a totally bizarre story